le aste immobiliari sono una forma di
acquisto alternativo rispetto alla
tradizionale compravendita che consentì
di aggiudicare i beni posti in vendita a
chi ha effettuato la migliore offerta le
aste consentono di effettuare acquisti
spesso a importo di prezzo molto
vantaggioso rispetto a quanto non
succeda nel tradizionale mercato delle
compravendite ciò le rende molto
attrattive ma per poter partecipare a
un'asta in modo fruttuoso
bisogna parteciparvi con consapevolezza
e quindi bisogna conoscere le aste
nell'immaginario collettivo le aste si
riducono alla sola fase della gara del
rilancio dove con rapidi cenni di mano o
del capo si arriva a un aggiudicazione
al miglior offerente ma quello è uno
stereotipo le aste non sono solo quello
le aste sono un mondo un mondo che si
compone di fasi procedurali ben definite
e di elementi emozionali spesso inattesi
e inaspettati le aste sono uno strumento
di vendita molto antico
anche lo stesso nome asta deriva dal
periodo dell'antica roma
e sapete perché vi siete mai chiesti
perché diciamo vendere ad acquistare
all'asta per che nell'antica roma a chi
voleva vendere i propri beni con questa
metodologia era uso porre nel terreno un
palo o un asta appunto a significare che
in quel luogo si sarebbe svolta la gara
fra i più sofferenti per
l'aggiudicazione dei beni stessi quindi
la vendita avveniva sotto l'asta o
vicino alla st
come diciamo noi quindi appunto all'asta
le aste possano essere di più tipologie
aste giudiziarie e quindi le aste
forzate tipicamente quelle derivanti da
esecuzioni immobiliari o da procedure
fallimentari ma anche aste volontarie
quelle tra privati o per la dismissione
dei beni di titolarità degli enti
pubblici
le aste hanno visto le proprie normative
e le proprie regolamentazioni
modernizzarsi perfezionarsi ad affinarsi
nel corso degli anni anche le aste
quindi possono essere definite oggi come
un prodotto adeguato ai tempi moderni un
prodotto 2.0
infatti le aste si svolgono
principalmente
mai con modalità telematica ciò che ha
consentito di evitare la presenza fisica
nel luogo dove la st si svolge per i
partecipanti e quindi ha consentito di
ampliare la platea dei soggetti a cui la
st si rivolge e consentire a questi
soggetti interessati a partecipare
all'asta un risparmio di tempi e anche
di denari tutta questa modernizzazione
questo essere così in formato telematico
delle aste potrebbe far pensare che le
aste siano qualcosa di freddo di
impersonale ma in realtà chi come me le
aste rivedete all'interno in qualità di
professionista incaricato vi può
assicurare che le aste sono tutt'altro
le aste sono un mondo un mondo che si
compone di fasi procedurali ben definite
e gli elementi emozionali stessa
inaspettato con molti volti e molte
anime
abbiamo un primo volto che può essere
quello del soggetto incaricato della st
stessa quindi volto pubblico ufficiale
nelle aste giudiziarie e tipicamente il
volto del giudice del custode
giudiziario del professionista delegato
del perito che i beni stima ma anche dei
cancellieri degli ausiliari nelle asse
tra privati più tipicamente notarili il
notaio banditore il notaio periferico
questi sono i professionisti a cui chi è
interessato a partecipare all'asta può
sempre anzi deve sempre rivolgersi con
fiducia sapendo che può così ottenere
indicazioni e consigli su come
partecipare e sulle caratteristiche
tipiche di quella specifica sta poi
abbiamo il volto molto eterogeneo di chi
all'asta partecipa come offerente
potenziale aggiudicatario
abbiamo persone che partecipano alle
aste solo per cercare di effettuare un
acquisto al miglior prezzo possibile
quindi solo per fini di investimento ma
abbiamo anche persone famiglie che si
avvicinano alle aste riponendo in esse i
propri sogni propri desideri perché
magari in quegli immobili hanno
individuato il bene in cui vogliono
iniziare un percorso di vita oppure
persone che partecipano ad aste
immobiliari dove i beni posti in vendita
sono di titolarità dei propri genitori o
di propri familiari per cercare di
evitare che l'assegnazione dei beni
venga effettuata a favore di soggetti
terzi e che la titolarità di quegli
immobili rimanga diciamo così nell'alveo
familiare
queste persone spesso portano con sé
tensioni emotive importanti e
soprattutto nella mia esperienza
manifestano timore di non riuscire ad
affrontare in modo corretto la fase
principale della spa quella della vera
propria gara fra i concorrenti in realtà
con i giusti consigli e le giuste
indicazioni vi assicuro è assolutamente
possibile partecipare all'asta ottenendo
anche risultati fruttuosi
la contropartita è il volto di chi
invece l'asta la subisce tipicamente
perché titolare dei beni posti in
vendita nelle aste giudiziarie e questo
significa per il professionista
incaricato
rapportarsi con persone con famiglie che
per un motivo o per l'altro della vita
non sono in una situazione facile e sono
in un momento critico del loro percorso
questi soggetti hanno una dignità e una
fragilità che deve essere sempre
rispettata compito del professionista e
quindi anche quello di far sì che la sta
sia meno invasiva possibile nei
confronti di queste persone se pur nel
rispetto delle normative che prevedono
il rilascio dei beni e la consegna degli
stessi al nuovo proprietario ed
aggiudicatario in realtà nella mia
esperienza chi subisce l'asta dopo una
prima diffidenza iniziale anche
comprensibile comprende che in realtà il
professionista incaricato non è il
nemico ma un soggetto che può
affiancarlo nel proprio cammino anche in
un momento di difficoltà e perché no le
aste possano anche essere un buon modo
per ricominciare
ho personalmente conosciuto famiglie che
dopo aver subito un asta hanno ri
partecipato a nuovi esperimenti di
vendita riuscendo ad aggiudicarsi un
nuovo immobile dove ricominciare il
proprio percorso di vita ma abbiamo
anche il volto del creditore che
dall'asta cerca di ottenere una
soddisfazione se non integrale perlomeno
parziale dei propri diritti creditori
essendo anche in attesa del risultato
dell'asta perché spesso sta cercando di
evitare a sua volta un momento di
criticità economica quindi le aste
racchiudono in sé molti volti molti anni
e compito dei professionisti incaricati
è anche quello di far sì che le aste
ottengano il miglior risultato possibile
per tutti i soggetti in esse coinvolti
mediando gli interessi appunto
presenti
ma
se siamo interessati a partecipare a
un'asta quali sono le fasi principali a
cui dovremmo partecipare e quali sono
gli elementi essenziali a cui porre
maggiore attenzione
ogni asta quale che ne sia la tipologia
prevederà innanzitutto una fase di
pubblicità per cui in tempo congruo
rispetto alla data fissata per lo
svolgimento dell'esperimento di vendita
verranno pubblicati normalmente su
canali online su siti piattaforme a ciò
deputate ma anche sulla buona vecchia
carta stampata tutte le indicazioni
documenti necessari per far sì che chi è
interessato alla st abbia tutti gli
elementi necessari per valutare se
quella sta effettivamente faccia proprio
caso in questa fase la parola che vi
dovrete tenere presente è
verificate verificate sempre tutta la
documentazione pubblicata in modo
attento facendovi aiutare e sostenere
dal professionista incaricato ma anche
da professionisti di vostra fiducia in
modo tale da poter valutare lo stato del
bene la sua situazione urbanistica al
sole il suo stato di possesso e di
occupazione ma anche gli altri elementi
dell'asta stessa il prezzo base
l'offerta minima se applicabile
l'importo della cauzione da versare i
termini per effettuare il saldo prezzo e
spese l'importo dei rilanci solo così
potrete partecipare in modo consapevole
all'asta e perché no avere anche un
risultato più fruttuoso una volta
individuata la sa di vostro interesse
la successiva fase quella della
presentazione delle offerte offerta che
normalmente potrà essere presentata sia
con modalità telematica sia con modalità
cartacea ciò che al più contribuirà a
definire la vostra partecipazione
all'asta al giorno dell'esperimento
partecipazione da tre moto in telematico
nel momento in cui presenta un'offerta
telematica partecipazione in presenza
nel momento in cui decidono di
presentare un'offerta modalità cartacea
tradizionale
l'offerta deve essere compilata in modo
corretto preciso e completo per poter
essere giudicata valida ed essere
ammessa la successiva fase quella della
vera e propria gara quindi la parola
chiave da ricordare in questa fase e
attenzione attenzione alla compilazione
in tutti i punti richiesti dell'offerta
stessa
fate attenzione anche e soprattutto alle
modalità di versamento della cauzione
una volta presentata l'offerta il giorno
dell'asta il professionista incaricato
aprirà tutte le offerte fino a quel
momento rimaste segrete ne valuterà la
validità quelle valutate valide e
giudicate ammissibili verranno appunto
ammesse alla vera e propria fase della
gara ecco la fase dei rilanci di cui
parlavamo in precedenza in questa fase
la parola chiave per voi è calma
mantenete la calma
ponderate le vostre scelte
non siate precipitosi nei rilanci
il tempo non passa così velocemente come
voi pensate e prima di iniziare la fase
della gara date di un budget di spesa
fissato una somma oltre la quale non
andare con i rilanci onde evitare di non
riuscire a far fronte al pagamento del
saldo prezzo e spese nei termini
previsti per quella specifica sta
rischiando così di perdere
l'aggiudicazione è anche la cauzione a
suo tempo versata una volta che sarete
risultati aggiudicatari della st ci sarà
la fase del fas aldo prezzo e spese
in questa fase la parola chiave è
tempestività perché saldo prezzo deve
essere effettuato entro il termine
previsto specificamente dall avviso di
vendita dal bando di gara o nell'offerta
pubblica essendo un termine normalmente
improrogabile e quindi che va
necessariamente rispettato
una volta effettuata a saldo prezzo e
spese che comporta anche il pagamento
delle imposte che sono le stesse che vi
trovereste dover pagare nel momento in
cui effettuare il vostro acquisto come
una normale tradizionale compravendita
ci sarà il vero e proprio trasferimento
dei beni a vostro favore ciò che nelle
aste giudiziarie avviene tipicamente
vedi mento con decreto del giudice
competente mentre nelle aste volontarie
avviene attraverso il normale atto di
trasferimento notarile a quel punto il
bene potrà essere riconsegnato e
entrerete in possesso del vostro nuovo
immobile
quindi le aste sono sicuramente
un'occasione per poter effettuare un
acquisto a prezzi interessanti
ma sapendo e avendo la certezza che la
presenza dei professionisti incaricati
garantirà sempre la serietà della st
stessa e la corretto svolgimento di
tutte le fasi procedurali che li
accompagneranno
a questo punto vi ricordate l'asta
dell'antica roma ecco quella st potrebbe
essere immaginata come un bastone
strumento che tipicamente sostiene i
nostri passi il nostro con il nostro
cammino con il bastone voi dovete
immaginarlo come personificato oggi nei
professionisti incaricati
soggetti che vi sapranno sempre
consigliare e saranno a vostra
disposizione per accompagnarvi nel
vostro percorso di partecipazione
all'asta quindi a me non resta che dirvi
buona partecipazione all'asta che avrete
individuato come di vostro interesse e
che vinca il migliore o meglio in questo
caso che vinca al miglior offerente